[Music]
the a's have been looking to build a new
waterfront ballpark in the east bay for
five years and they're still negotiating
that step toward relocation may or may
not be closer to reality after today's
meetings here is sports director chris
matthews joining us with the very latest
on a meeting held today well these
meetings have been going on and on brian
we're following these talks because the
a's have expressed interest in las vegas
if they can't get the ballpark built in
oakland board of supervisors in alameda
county met with city leaders and the
president of the oakland a's dave cable
took center stage in a virtual meeting
to discuss the six billion dollar
project telling the board it would
generate 400 million in community
benefits discussions have dragged out
now for five years and even with a vote
today they'd still go back and negotiate
with oakland city leaders concerns from
the county center around the enormous
six billion dollar price tag associated
with the waterfront ballpark district a
gigantic mixed-use project with a
stadium affordable housing business
district and more but there is a reason
the commissioner of baseball allowed the
a's to look elsewhere beyond the bay
it's dragged on so long and you know
frankly in some ways we're not sure we
see
a path to success in terms of getting
something built in oakland
we recently spoke with the a's president
about one of their many visits to las
vegas and they're certainly impressed
with our city they've met with many las
vegas city leaders and